لذلك اسمحوا لي أن آخذ بعضًا من هذه القضايا
لأنهم جميعًا مهمون حقًا
فكرة تجنب
الضم ،
أعني أنك ربما قرأت هآرتس ، فأنت
تعلم أنهم قالوا بشكل أساسي إن
بيبي نتنياهو لم يكن لديه خطة
فعلية لضمه  لم يقدم أبدًا خطة إلى
البرلمان ،
لم يكن هناك أي شيء رسمي
ظنوا أنه كان
كما تعلمون نوعًا ما من النفوذ
الذي كان لديه ، والآن حصل على هذا
الاعتراف الدبلوماسي منك
، وحتى تلك اللحظة قال إنه
لا يزال على  الجدول قرأته
لجاريد كوشنر كما ترون
، واعترف جاريد كوشنر أن هذا
هو الوقت الحالي في الوقت الحالي ،
وقد تم إبعاد هذا الضم عن
أي نفوذ لديك وهل
تعتقد أن هذا تم إيقافه
إلى الأبد مرة أخرى مسيحي لا شيء
إلى الأبد
لكن ما أه الواضح بالنسبة لي
هو التفريق الواضح
بين سياسة الدولة
والتزامات الدولة وبالنسبة
لي أنا
أفرق بينهما لأن
لديكم هنا التزام واضح  nts أعني أن
الولايات المتحدة
متورطة في عملية
التطبيع أيضًا هي
عملية لن تحدث غدًا أو
بعد غد وفي نفس الوقت لدى
إسرائيل حقًا فرصة الآن في
أه حقًا تخلق ثقة
مع اقتصاد عربي كبير بلد
ليس لها حدود مع إسرائيل حقًا ،
لذا سأفرق حقًا
بين السياسات الغامضة لجميع
دول الشرق الأوسط والخطاب الذي نسمعه ، لكن
التزامات
الدول سأخبرك أننا في
اتصالاتنا مع العديد من
العواصم العربية والعديد من الدول الأوروبية  لقد
كانت قضية الضم في
الواقع بمثابة قنبلة موقوتة كان
الجميع قلقًا بشأنها ، لذا
فقد تناولنا
قضية الضم هذه من الجدول
الذي اشتريناه ، ولن أقول
إن هذا الأمر
إلى الأبد ولكنه بالفعل كذلك.
امنحونا الوقت لأن خلاف ذلك كان
حل الدولتين قد مات